on the mound for the marlins it's 6-0
sanchez third big league start and
they're two house
well jonathan vr with a base hit
swinging at the first pitch we saw a lot
of that and he will go for second jazz's
throw is right there and they get him
trying to be aggressive and thrown out
trying to stretch that into a hustle
double instead turns out to essentially
be a one two three first inning
what he's done over his last five starts
he's given up one or
zero earned runs in five straight starts
and it'll be birdie marte and cooper
it's the curve ball that he wanted and
he freezes him for strike three call
a fly ball to shallow right field off
the bat of starling marche and hernandez
makes the catch cooper's on with a walk
that'll bring jesus aguilar to the plate
hence a ground ball down to third wide
of the bag shaw goes sliding to his
knees and makes it on target two way for
lourdes gorilla junior here's the ground
ball towards the middle and through a
base hit guriel just shoots this past
the right side of the mound and it rolls
into the grass for a base hit now an
extreme shift by miami against shaw the
pitch and that's box to slider glances
out of the glove of el faro breaking
towards second guriel stops snap throw
down to first he goes back standing and
he's tagged out
two innings and two base running
mistakes two runners lost on the bases
vr in the first and now guriel in the
second he's late deciding that he wants
to go then he realizes he's in trouble
then he tries to get back and then he
doesn't slide or dive back to the bag
and he's thrown out on the third inning
leadoff man john bertie there's a ground
ball back to the mound snared by ryu a
nice play and he'll flip it to first to
retire birdie for the first half birdie
hit it right back up the middle and ryu
just stuck that glove down and found
himself a baseball garrett cooper the
2-2 swing and a miss got him with a 67
mile an hour curveball
jonathan v art
and another base hit to left field for
vr the second one of the night
and this time he's not going to take any
chances with t oscar hernandez at the
plate
and a base hit into left center
vr around second on his way to third the
throw will come into second and that is
now a 14 game hitting streak for t oscar
hernandez so the blue jays with an
opportunity albeit with two outs in the
inning first and third for rowdy teles
runner is going they'll throw to third
unbelievable
they throw to third and they get vr
oscar was running they put the play on
to go to third and sure enough another
base runner had raced the marlins and
the blue jays have no score it's the
first time they've had the lead-off man
on in the game tonight and here's goriel
had a base hit and then he was picked
off at first base by the catcher
and now a fly ball to left center field
and this ball is well hit and it's gone
goriel hits one out his fifth of the
season and the blue jays have taken the
lead look like a slider that guriel
barrelled up and hits it out of the
ballpark it's the fifth home run for
gurio two out single and the tying runs
are aboard in the fifth inning so great
speed on the bases for garrett cooper
that's into center it is gonna get down
birdie coming around third base throw
from biggio is cut off and it's two to
one and this is what i love about coupe
goop's a big guy he's got tons of power
we talked about home run distance over
the last two ball games but that's
taking a 90 mile an hour pitch and not
trying to do too much he didn't get ever
out and around that ball and hit a
ground ball to the left side he stayed
inside it fought it off and dumped it in
center field two quick round ball out
for six though six though now through
six and two thirds has allowed the two
runs on six hits he hasn't walked
anybody and he has four strikeouts well
how about six dos sanchez another
strikeout making the seventh inning look
easy here we go to the ninth inning
jimmy garcia comes on to do the pitching
now for the marlins on randall grichik a
1-2
and a swing and a miss goes upstairs at
96 miles an hour jonathan vr
ground ball that's jazz up with it
and makes the throw over to cooper so
tay oscar hernandez at first roddy
tallest here's a ground ball to the
second baseman birdie has it throws to
first inning is over and the blue jays
take a one run lead to the bottom of the
ninth in miami and hand the ball to
anthony bass top of the order john
bertie the blue jays are one out away
ground ball bouncer to second on to
first and the blue jays will win it
another one run game they find a way to
win this one guriel with a home run to
drive in the only two runs of the night
for the jays